pendant la parole à jean-marc jancovici
donc on va passer à l'ingénieur est bon
alors deux
je vais pas porter de jugement son
programme mais je suis pas sûr que leurs
chais demandes d intervention suivent un
ordre logique parfaitement défini mais
c'est pas grave
donc on va demander de raconter ce que
je raconte donc je raconte donc la
question qu'on m'a posée c'est comment
est ce qu'on fait pour faire quelque
chose de construit à d'europe en partant
de langue énergétique
donc je vais faire comme on fait
d'habitude les devoir de philo parce que
je crois que même dans cet établissement
fait de philo aussi enfin toujours dans
la sphère en entrée donc on va essayer
de dérouler le problème en petits
morceaux
le premier petit morceau alors je suis
infiniment désolés pour les quelques
têtes connues que je reconnais dans
cette salle donc vous pouvez regarder
votre smartphone pendant ce temps là
vous allez entendre un truc que vous
connaissez par coeur
c'est juste mais s'il ya une personne
dans cette salle qui j'apprends quelque
chose c'est quand même pas perdu mon
temps c'est de vous rappeler ce dont on
parle quand on parle d'énergie
je vous appelle et donc dans ce temple
de l'enseignement scientifique ça
devrait pas vous étonner que l'énergie
c'est par définition ce qui quantifie de
changement d'état d'un système d'accord
donc quand on parle d'énergie on parle
de transformation du monde physique qui
nous entoure on n'a pas parlé d'argent
très souvent évidemment quand on parle
d'énergie dans un débat les gens en
pensent à leur facture et on n'a
absolument pas parlé de nucléaire contre
éolien on a parlé d' une notion qui est
dans le monde physique la quantification
de la transformation
quand on dit que les gens utilisent de
l'énergie en fait c'est un terme
impropre
ça veut dire qu'ils ont maîtrisé un
processus de transformation c'est ça que
ça veut dire donc utiliser de l'énergie
c'est maîtriser un processus de
transformation
ça ne veut rien dire vous savez que
l'énergie est régi par un certain nombre
de lois physiques que vous ne changez
pas par un vote à l'assemblée nationale
c'est ce qui les rend particulièrement
désagréables aux yeux des politiques qui
essayent périodiquement de demander à
leur administration de violer les lois
de l'énergie d'administration du mal à y
arriver donc une partie deviendra
stennicke une autre part en dépression
et la troisième foule quand à prier
rigolez pas c'est à peu près ce qu'on
observe aujourd'hui dans un certain
nombre d'administrations et j'ai des
témoignages de première main car je vous
racontais un truc que je raconte pas
d'habitude
venant ddf ou de rte de gens qui me
disent qu'on les empêche d'exprimer des
faits avérés
parce que c'est contraire la ligne
politique du moment voilà il faut savoir
que ça existe dans notre pays au moment
où je vous parle donc le à cause d'eux
une des lois qui régissent la question
énergétique qui est la loi de
conservation tout ce que les hommes
peuvent faire c'est d'exploiter à leur
profit une énergie qui sort
l'environnement voilà on sait rien faire
d'autre que d'exploiter à notre profit
une énergie qui sort de l'environnement
alors historiquement la seule énergie
sortie de l'environnement qu'on a
exploité ces trucs qui se mangeaient et
l'asean conversion qu'on était capable
d'opérer c'était celle que l'on faisait
dans notre propre organisme
avec beaucoup de chaleur renouvelable
très sympathique un peu de mouvements
renouvelables très sympathique un peu de
mots croisés de temps en temps mais
voilà donc le cmec propre corps qu'on
met en mouvement avec de l'énergie
extraite de l'environnement qui est de
l'énergie contenue dans les trucs qu'on
mange
et puis les ingénieurs géniaux issus de
cette école et d'autres dans
intéressante au fil du temps mis au
point d'autres convertisseur énergétique
qui avait le grand intérêt de ne pas
nous faire concurrence sur la nourriture
et de pouvoir manger de l'énergie qui
venait d'ailleurs en particulier du sous
sol donc du sous sol c'est bien parce
que ça ne fait pas concurrence sur la
nourriture et d'avoir la capacité de
convertir l'énergie avec des ordres de
grandeur qui nous était totalement
inaccessible
c'est ça les machines et non en pratique
aujourd'hui parce que vous allez voir
dans pas longtemps l'énergie des
machines dépasse de quelques ordres de
grandeurs l'énergie consommée par les
hommes
et bien aujourd'hui en pratique
comprenez qu'à chaque fois qu'on vous
dit on consomme plus d'énergie il faut
entendre que l'on n'utilise plus de
machines et inversement que quand on
vous dit qu'on va faire des économies
d'énergie c'est à dire pour en faire des
économies de machines au premier ordre
c'est à peu près de ça quand on est en
train de peindre alors
aujourd'hui on a coutume de dire qu'on a
un problème avec les énergies fossiles
je vais quand même très rapidement
rappelé que en deux siècles on s'est
ingénié à faire l'exact inverse à chaque
fois qu'on a eu on avait de la marine
renouvelable
la voix si on est passé à de la maille
pas renouvelables parce qu'on a trouvé
que ça marche ait lieu on avait du
transport renouvelables on est passé aux
transports pas renouvelables parce qu'on
a trouvé que ça marchait mieux on avait
de l'agriculture renouvelables on est
passés à l'agriculture pas renouvelables
parce qu'on trouvait que ça marche et
lieux etc etc donc d'une manière
générale on a passé notre temps
ces derniers siècles ces deux derniers
siècles à passer d'une énergie
renouvelable était absolument
merveilleuse parce qu'elle est
renouvelable
c'est qu'elle doit être merveilleuse à
une énergie fossile tout à fait
diabolique alors en fait si on a fait ça
il ya une raison physique et je vais
reprendre un petit calcul d'ordre de
grandeur que certains d'entre vous
connaissent
si vous mettez un mouvement en l'air de
cette pièce qui au premier rang est à
peu près le volume d'un cube de 10
mètres de côté à une vitesse de 45
noeuds et que vous faites passer ça dans
une éolienne
vous allez récupérer à l'arrivée la même
quantité d'énergie que ce que vous avez
dans 3000 litres de pétrole j'en fais
pas beaucoup trop mais de pétrole c'est
une autre manière de dire que l'énergie
renouvelable qui est à gauche
la collecter dans l'environnement là
concentrée et la rendre disponible à la
demande par exemple en
broyant des grains pour en faire de la
farine sel d'énergie disponibles à la
demande la farine vous manger quand vous
avez faim et bien c'est quelque chose
qui est considérablement plus compliqué
que d'aller faire un trou là où il ya du
pétrole est de faire sortir du pétrole
et comme c'est plus compliqué ça demande
plus de bonhomme pour être mis en oeuvre
et comme l'argent ne paye que des hommes
c'est ça le propre du système économique
c'est que l'abonné ne payent tous des
hommes ça paye pas la nature ça paye que
des hommes est bien à gauche ça va
coûter beaucoup plus cher qu'à droite
parce qu'il faut mettre en jeu beaucoup
plus de paires de bras et beaucoup plus
de paires de jambes est beaucoup plus de
cervelle aujourd'hui pour extraire la
même quantité de kilowattheures de
l'environnement sorti d'une éolienne
aujourd'hui le kilowattheure vous coûte
quelques centimes alors aujourd'hui dans
les meilleures conditions possibles et
c'est dans des pays où la main d'oeuvre
est pas cher on descend à 4 mais peu
importe quoi ça reste toujours dix fois
plus cher que le kilowattheure de
pétrole sorti de terre que vous avez à
droite qui lui possède déjà sa fonction
de stock alors que la gauche pour le
moment le train avance quand il ya du
vent et quand les cheminots sont pas en
règle bah oui voilà il faut aussi des
bonnes âmes mais vous avez donc à gauche
quelque chose qui n'est pas encore
stockés qui vaut 6 à 8 centimes dans les
pays occidentaux
après quelque chose qui est déjà stocké
équivaut à 0 3 centime
donc en fait la raison pour laquelle on
est passé de l'énergie renouvelable à
l'énergie fossile c'est parce que pour
considérablement moins de travail humain
vous pouvez générer peut
considérablement plus de flux physiques
de transformer toutes les ressources qui
vous intéressent
en d'autres trucs qui vous intéresse
encore plus donc transformé lumière fr
enfourche est ce que c'est plus pratique
de manger des oeufs sans faire des
tâches sur la cravate avec une
fourchette et du minerai de fer
transformée et du fils en chaussettes
parce que ça donc c'est exactement ça
qu'on a cherché à faire depuis dessus
des 7 énergie met donc en oeuvre des
machines qui sont vachement plus
puissante que vous
donc nous en fait quand vous regardez
les forts qu'on est capable de faire
c'est quelques secondes quelques
dizaines de watts une centaines de watts
quelqu'un qui donne sur le mont blanc
par exemple dans la journée quatre mille
mètres de dénivelé vous fait jeu égal
mgh vous vous rendez compte c'est un
kilowattheures d'énergie
donc s'il met 10 heures pour faire 500
watts au terrible là vous voyez vous
prenez les premiers tracteurs venus ces
quelques dizaines de kilowatts
vous prenez la première engins de
travaux publics venus ces quelques
milliers de paires de bras
donc les cinq cent mille logements on
rêve de construire aujourd'hui avec
juste des pelles des pioches et des gens
qui taillent la pierre avec des pics
vous oublier voilà pour faire le
cornichon en bas résille à la défense la
tour d2 il a fallu six mois
psychanalyse et l'architecte qui a fait
ça non c'est pas d'accord ou
psychanalyse s'est désolé optique adayé
d'architectes qui a fait sa ba c'est un
cornichon en bas résille tu peux déjà vu
cette tour
c'est une grosse brésil un cornichon par
énigmes et bien il a fallu six mois je
sais pas
enfin pour faire le gros oeuvre il a
fallu six mois alors que pour ériger une
structure donner une dimension à
l'époque du moyen-age
il fallait 50 ou 100 ans donc tout ça
c'est leur produit des machines que nous
avons là et sur lesquels bien évidemment
on a bâti aujourd'hui des programmes
politiques et des programmes sociaux qui
considère que ce truc là va rester
acquis pour l'éternité dorée je vais
vous montrer après que c'est très
exactement comme ça qu'ils ont rédigé
les textes européens
quand on vous présente l'évolution de la
quantité d'énergie utilisée dans le
monde ou par personne peu importe
et bien que vous avez ici par exemple
traduit en kilowattheures sur un siècle
et demi et bien vous pouvez le lire
comme quantité d'énergie consommée mais
vous pouvez aussi de lire comme quantité
de machines qui fonctionnent et en fait
c'est surtout comme quantité de machines
qui fonctionnent qu'il faut les
comprendre alors sachant avec le type
qui grimpe sur le mont blanc là tout à
l'heure je vous ai dit un kilowattheure
en une journée mais c'est maximum
maximorum de ce que vous pouvez faire en
fait un corps humain il peut fournir
quelques dizaines de kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique dans une année ce
qui veut dire que l'énergie utilisée par
les hommes aujourd'hui représentent les
en fait ça signifie que chaque personne
à sa disposition un parc de machines qui
est 200 fois plus puissant que son
propre corps c'est ça que ça signifie
donc utiliser de l'énergie
en fait c'est avoir créé de toutes
pièces une exoplanète 2400 milliards
d'euros hommes qui pédalent en
permanence et qui nous fournissent
l'énergie mécanique correspondante
c'est ça utiliser de l'énergie c'est ça
que ça veut dire est ce qu'il faut en
fait comprendre quand vous voyez cette
courbe ah c'est pas consommation
d'énergie c'est quantité de machines en
service alors en fait c'est encore plus
rapide que ça sur la quantité de
machines en service parce que
l'efficacité unitaire d'une machine a
par ailleurs augmenté au cours du temps
alors là aussi vous avez des limites
absolues
tout à l'heure on a rappelé que
fallait une source chaude d'une source
froide ce qu'arnaud à 10 ans montait de
sûreté un pays vous y couper pas mais
l'efficacité des premières machines
thermiques il ya très très longtemps et
est très très loin de la moité de sûreté
1 et maintenant on demande est beaucoup
plus près ceci allant avec cela quand
vous transformer l'environnement dans le
cadre d'une activité productive donc
vous prenez les sociétés dans lesquelles
geneviève à travailler parce qu'il a
travaillé d'un grand capital rendent
être de découvrir qu'elle avait une âme
voilà mais tout arrive dans la vie grand
capital coté en bourse
l'horreur absolue et bien quand vous
dans ces sociétés
vous avez des processus de
transformation donc pour prendre une
société par exemple qui s'appelle veolia
au hasard vous annuel va travailler
vous prenez des ressources de départ qui
sont de l'eau disponible dans
l'environnement du minerai de fer
disponible dans l'environnement du
pétrole disponible dans l'environnement
vous transformer tout ça en tuyaux en
plastique tuyaux en fonte et machines
déploration de l'eau et vous amener
l'eau potable chez vous c'est une
transformation
par ailleurs veolia vous envoie une
facture cette facture est représentatif
d'une valeur ajoutée corps donc veolia à
ajouter de la valeur en fait ajouter de
la valeur c'est avoir payé des gens
qu'on travaillait au sein de la société
c'est ça avoir ajouté puisque l'argent
ne paye que des hommes c'est ça et quand
vous faites la totalité des valeurs a
ajouté que vous avez dans un pays vous
obtenez ce fameux pays des qui
aujourd'hui est devenu le graal des
économistes est ce que vous dit ce
graphique
c'est une chose très simple c'est que
pour avoir plus de valeur ajoutée
globale dans le monde
c'est à dire plus de pib eh bien vous ne
savez pas faire autrement dans notre
monde de machines aujourd'hui que
d'augmenter la quantité de machines qui
fonctionnent et donc la quantité
d'énergie que vous utilisez et
l'augmentation sur la période vous voyez
elle est quasi linéaire elle est quasi
dr
donc moi je suis pour le remplacement
des modèles dgse par des droites
je pense qu'on ferait des économies
budgétaires et qu'on dirait une connerie
du doigt la fois merveilleux voilà donc
vous voyez ici la traduction logique de
ce que je viens de raconter c'est à dire
du rapport doit à 200 que vous avez
entre la puissance musculaire de
l'humanité et la puissance du parc de
machines qui est en fonctionnement à
tout instant dans le monde 1 200 est
alors pour comme tant d'autres plus
grand malheur l'énergie que nous
utilisons est majoritairement fossiles
parce que si justement ça qu'on a
cherché à faire pour augmenter notre
puissance ne peut pas être
majoritairement renouvelables quand on
était majoritairement renouvelables on
était cinq cents millions d'agriculteurs
tranports l'espérance de vie à la
naissance
c'est justement parce que voilà donc
100% venir soit dit en passant il ya pas
besoin de faire faire une étude par
l'ademe pour savoir qui est possible
c'est possible à 500 millions
d'agriculteurs et 30 ans d'espérance de
vie à des sangsues sûr que c'est
possible
7 milliards d' homo industrialise 70 ans
et le pib qui justifie enfin pardon oui
le pouvoir d'achat qui justifie qu'on se
met en grève quand ils baissent moins
sûr donc ici vous avez le drame faustien
qui est le nôtre c'est le début du
mauvais côté du pacte faustien c'est que
on ne sait pas augmenter la
transformation c'est à dire le nombre de
machines au travail sans augmenter la
quantité d'énergie fossiles qu'on
utilise précisément parce que la
puissance unitaire de ces machines à
l'énergie fossile n'a rien à voir avec
les bateaux à voile et avec les gens
qu'ils cultivaient les champs avec des
pelles et des pioches et quand vous
voyez ça et c'est là que je vais revenir
sur l'europe
vous avez quand même beaucoup de mal à
avaler l'idée qu'on va faire de la
croissance verte c'est à dire l'idée que
dans le même temps le pib il va
continuer à partir vers le haut la
advitam eternam
pendant que le co2 il va repartir vers
le bas et qu'on va arriver à zéro
vous voyez ça vous dit je demande à voir
normalement un peu plus que dans un
slogan politique alors ce que en termes
de flux ce que je vous ai raconté
c'est vous avez des hydrocarbures et des
ressources et un peu partout je vous
rappelle que tout ça est gratuit un
autre truc aussi pour ceux d'entre vous
qui ne l'est pas dit le vent est gratuit
mais le pétrole n'est tout autant un
personne dans cette salle n'a payé le
moindre centime pour former le pétrole
il ya des gens qui ont la bonne idée
d'être ainsi dessus ça c'est rien à voir
mais le fait d'avoir formé le pétrole
personne dans cette salle tu as payé le
moindre centime personne dans cette
salle n'a payé le moindre centime pour
que existe les 92 éléments du tableau de
mendeleïev sur terre ça c'est la
génération des toiles l'avant le soleil
qui s'en est chargé donc personne dans
cette salle n'a payé le moindre centime
pour qu'existe la planète terre et ses
ressources
donc le prix d'une ressource en fait ce
n'est pas le prix de la ressource et le
prix de la personne qui la détient ou du
le chat ou le prix qu'il faut payer le
militaire pour aller lui passer sur le
corps on a prié deux options et le prix
ben oui on a les deux et le prix de la
personne qui travaille physiquement pour
l'extraire mais c'est jamais la
ressource elle-même que vous payez donc
les hydrocarbures sont gratuits comme le
reste grâce à l'énergie qu'ils nous ont
fournis on a été capable de transformer
toutes les autres sources que nous offre
l'environnement est en fait au premier
ordre
la rareté d'une autre ressource c'est la
quantité d'énergie qu'il faut dépenser
pour aller la chercher
je parle des ressources minérales je
parle pas de la biodiversité parce que
ça met du pétrole n'arrive pas à recréer
le code génétique d'un type en mai si je
parle des ressources minérales et de ce
qu'on est capable d'en faire c'est
essentiellement une question d'énergie
et à ce moment on est capable de faire
tout ce qui nous environne est par
ailleurs on est capable d'augmenter la
productivité du travail et en augmentant
la productivité du travail on est
capable de libérer du temps pour des
fonctions tertiaires on est capable de
mettre les gens en ville on est capable
d'allonger les études on est capable de
partir à la retraite plus tôt d'avoir
six semaines dix semaines à la sncf et
chef de congés payés
voilà tout ça c'est le fruit de
l'énergie abondante
tout ça c'est le fruit de l'énergie
abondante dont le prix est gratuit je
rappelle le coût d'extraction lui il
existe il faut payer des gens pour ça
l'énergie elle-même vaut rien
voilà et donc notre sacro-saint pib il
est simplement une manière de conter la
transformation quand je vais de ce qu'il
ya là et là vers deux facteurs limitants
s'applique à ce truc là un don l'europe
s'occupe un peu en ce moment le
changement climatique
alors vous allez voir qu'en fait elle
s'en occupe sauf qu'elle s'en occupe pas
parce qu'elle peut pas vraiment s'en
occuper parce que dans le traité de
l'union européenne dont je vais vous
montrer un article dans pas longtemps on
veut tout et son contraire à la fois
exactement comme dans les objectifs du
développement durable donc je vais
vraiment désolé de dire ça devant
geneviève mais vous prenez les dix sept
objectifs du développement durable
delaunay vous en prenez n'importe quel
des 17 au hasard il est antagoniste avec
au moins un des dix sept par ailleurs
d'accord c'est au sens propre le beurre
l'argent du beurre est ce que vous
voulez du crédit et de la crémière
c'est ça les dix sept objectifs du
développement durable donc vous êtes
sûrs pour les autres qui ravagerait
c'est ne pas avoir choisi donc c'est de
rien faire est un problème dont l'europe
se contrefout qui est la disponibilité
des énergies fossiles alors je vais vous
montrer dans pas longtemps que elle a
tort de s'en contrefoutent parce que le
problème est déjà à l'oeuvre
mais je vous assure pour avoir discuté
avec un certain nombre de gens très
hauts placés à la direction générale de
l'énergie de la commission européenne
que la disponibilité future de l'énergie
fossile est un non-sujet absolue sauf
éventuellement pour le gaz russe
le gaz russe ça nous turlupine un peu le
reste on s'en fout comme de l'an 40
alors on a tort parce qu'il se trouve
que la quantité d'énergie disponible par
personne dans le monde elle commence
déjà à donner des signes d'essouflement
notamment à cause de ce qui se passe sur
le pétrole
et vous allez voir que ça se traduit
directement dans l'économie vous avez
ici l'évolution de la quantité d'énergie
disponible par personne dans le monde
donc ça c'est une moyenne mondiale
vous voyez que depuis les chocs
pétroliers sahara était d'augmenter
significativement et c'est depuis les
chocs pétroliers qu'on commence à avoir
dans les pays de l' ocde du chômage de
la dette et c'est à l'évidence un
rapport entre ceci et cela
c'est remonter avant 2007 et vous voyez
que depuis 2007 s'est de nouveau flat
alors j'ai une courbe à vous proposer
sur la production industrielle par
personne dans le monde
elle démarre plus tard démarrant 90
alors que la précédente démarrer 1,65
donc si vous regardez la forme que ça à
partir de 90 et que vous regardez la
cour que je vous montre là c'est un
calque c'est un calque et vous avec la
production industrielle par personne
elle stagne depuis 2007 et la crise
financière de 2009 ce parti des gens qui
pensent que c'est juste une traduction
de ça c'est juste une traduction de sang
regardez maintenant l'attend la quantité
d'énergie disponible par personne dans
l'union européenne donc la quantité de
machines au travail par personne dans
l'union européenne
vous avez deux temps sur cette courbe un
arrêt de la croissance au moment des
chocs pétroliers et un début de la
décroissance après une longue période de
stabilité en 2005 donc 2005 en fait
c'est le deuxième choc énergétique
majeur connu par la civilisation
occidentale
le premier c'était les chocs pétroliers
changement de dérivés brusque arrêt de
la croissance de l'énergie disponible
par personne
deuxième changement de dérivés brusque
2005-2006 pardon 2006 et deux ans avant
lehman brothers donc c'est pas en
consommer moins de pétrole parce que
lehman brothers s'est cassé la gueule
c'est d'abord j'ai eu moins d'énergie
l'économie a ralenti et comme lehman
brothers reposait sur une espèce de
pyramide de ponzi puis laval maurer
s'est cassé la gueule c'est dans l'autre
sens pyramide de ponzi dans un monde en
croissance perpétuelle on s'en fout
marche très bien pas de problème
par contre la pyramide de ponzi dans un
monde sans croissance ça marche pas et
alors regardez en ce qui concerne le pib
par personne et donc j'en arrive à
l'europe en europe au moment des trente
glorieuses donc avant les premiers chocs
pétroliers
le pib par personne augmente de 4% par
an donc c'est l'époque à laquelle mes
parents en fait la croissance leur donne
leur maison quasiment alors ça s'est
traduit sous forme d'une inflation qui
effaçait les taux d'intérêt
alors à donner leur a donné leur maison
quoi lots achetés non mais voilà on les
augmente est de 5% ou 10% tous les ans
en fait on leur a donné un bon pendant
ou l'énergie s'arrête de croître alors
ya des gains d'efficacité résiduelles et
puis commence à y avoir une
financiarisation de l'économie qui
induit du pib un peu artificiel donc ça
c'est les ce qu'on appelle parfois les
trente piteuses
et puis arrive la période post 2006
et là vous voyez que le pib par personne
n'augmente quasiment plus les et les
portugais les espagnols rentrent dans
l'europe en 85 86 donc il rentre au
milieu de la période dite des trente
piteuses donc le pib global le gâteau
globale continue d'augmenter
donc à ce moment on peut leur vendre un
marché qui est nous on va faire ça
pendant que vous allez faire ça encore
plus vite parce que dans un univers en
croissance vous pouvez augmenter les
ressources de tout le monde se pose pas
de problème par contre une fois que
l'univers devient stable
tout ce que les uns vont avoir les
autres non plus dans un monde stable les
effets d'éviction sont légion vous ne
pouvez pas bougé une oreille quelque
part sans engendrer des effets
d'éviction ailleurs c'est impossible
arithmétiquement à ce moment on fait
rentrer les pays d'aix tard j'ai rien
contre les pays de l'est une partie de
ma famille romaine d'origine mais on
fait rentrer les pays de l'est
et puis on leur dit en gros on va
rejouer le coup des espagnols et des
portugais
nos problèmes donc nous on va continuer
à faire ça quand vous vous allez faire
ça pas de pot le gâteau stopper le
gâteau global devient stable
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe il se passe
que tout ce que les gens de l'est va
voir comme ça les gens de l'ouest ont la
voir comme ça en pratique ça se
matérialise de deux manières
lusine renault qui était en france par
en roumanie et le plombier qui étaient
en pologne par londres et puis un jour
on demande aux anglais est ce que ça
vous plaît dix noms
ils n'ont pas réfléchi est ce que le
déficit commercial non non non on leur a
dit est ce que vous êtes content d'avec
la manière dont les choses se passent
grâce à la libre circulation des
personnes de l'atelier où l'on n'est pas
content qui voit la patte
soit dit en passant c'est exactement le
même processus aux états unis voilà la
quantité d'énergie disponible par
personne aux états unis vous
reconnaissez les mêmes de temps choc
pétrolier et 2005 et les mêmes trois
temps sur le pib par personne et le même
type de réponse au niveau de l'électorat
alors ça vous fait marrer moi ça me fait
pas marrer du tout parce que je pense
que l'europe aujourd'hui est aveugle sur
les causes profondes de ce qui est en
train de se passer et quand vous êtes
aveugle sur les causes profondes de ce
qui est en train de se passer
la probabilité que vous trouviez une
réponse adaptée à la situation est nul
donc on va continuer à s'occuper de
conneries qu'ils vont soit ne pas
traiter le problème soit la grave et
c'est ça qu'on va continuer à faire
alors voilà à premier sujet par exemple
sur lesquels l'europe est aveugle
vous avez ici l'évolution de la quantité
totale d'énergie donc je le redis de
machines disponibles dans l'union depuis
alors vous voyez pour ceux d'entre vous
à qui ce mot ne fait pas peur une courbe
qui offre une superbe concavité super
pour éviter la quasi totalité des
économistes nous disent non mais
regardez on tire un trait là puis vous
voyez bien savoir partir faites moi
confiance je vais tourner les potards
dans les bons sens il faut libéraliser
le marché du travail
abaisser les tarifs douaniers sais pas
quoi où les montées au contraire
défendre au maître du boeuf aux hormones
ou au contraire longueur soit pas brad
et moi je dis ouais sauf que si vous
prolongez non pas la dérive et met à
dériver secondes vous obtenez la courbe
du bras l'a pas du tout la même gueule
à titre personnel je parle plus
facilement pour des raisons géologiques
que je suis capable d'expliquer sur
quelque chose qui se rapproche de la
courbe du bas que sur quelque chose qui
se rapproche de la cour duo donc mon
pari c'est qu'à partir de maintenant il
faut gérer une europe sans conscience et
non seulement sans croissance mais en
contraction
alors ça vous renverse tout est ce que
vous continuez à mettre des allocs pour
que les gens fassent plein d'enfants
dans un monde en contraction
d'autre part une très bonne idée est ce
que vous dites que non mais pas le sujet
n'est pas le sujet je le redis dans un
monde sans croissance les effets
d'éviction sont légion vous ne pouvez
pas bougé une oreille sans qu'ailleurs
il ya quelqu'un qui souffre c'est
impossible
arithmétiquement voilà alors on est là à
cause de lui je le rappelle il avait dit
que les volumes étaient pas dans les
prix 1
voilà et du coup on a un tout petit
sujet parce que l'union elle elle
résonne prix alors elle a un article 20
ans fait exactement l'alinéa 1 de
l'article 3 qui dit un truc auquel je
souscris parfaitement elle dit l'union
est là pour préserver la paix préservé
la paix c'est parfait donc à la limite
le traité instituant l'union européenne
aurait dû se limiter à cet article il
aurait dû dire voilà on est là pour
faire la paix puis maintenant à chaque
fois qu'on a un problème on se met
autour d'une table avec un peu de bon
sens et on se dit qu'est ce qui préserve
le mieux la paix manque de pot elle a
rajouté ça et alors c'est là que les
problèmes commencent
parce qu'elle a dit non non on va faire
la paix d'accord mais on va faire un
marché
sauf qu'il ya plein de cas de figure
dans lesquelles le marché est un
adversaire de la paix en particulier
quand vous êtes quand vous mettez dans
le marché des infrastructures qui sont
des monopoles naturels en univers contre
1 vous êtes sûr de ne faire qu'une chose
c'est la destruction capitale
c'est ça que vous allez faire d'accord
donc quand vous mettez dans le marché la
production électrique ou les chemins de
fer ou n'importe quoi qui est un
maquereau système parce que vous n'avez
pas avoir deux autoroutes paris nantes
et vous allez pas avoir deux réseaux
électriques de transport de
l'électricité
et vous n'allez pas non plus avoir de
réseau ferroviaire concurrents sur la
même destination ou éventuellement avoir
deux compagnies concurrentes mais vous
n'allez pas en avoir 50
donc dès que vous mettez dans le marché
quelque chose qui à cause de la lourdeur
des investissements est un monopole
naturel en fait ce qui se passe c'est
que vous constituez un oligopole c'est
ça que vous avez à l'arrivée avec de la
destruction de capital et si en plus le
zygo paul et financiarisée sa stratégie
long terme ces trois ans il presse le
capital autant qu'il peut il investit
pas d'accord dont vous avez raccourci
les échéances temporel et vous vous êtes
empêché de gérer l'épreuve de long terme
c'est exactement ça que vous avez fait
alors je dis pas que le monopole c'est
toujours bien géré après il faut savoir
ce qu'on veut mais je dis juste que
l'idée que en mettant un marché partout
et tout le temps vous allez régler tous
les problèmes tels qu'ils se présentent
ce qui est quand même assez largement le
credo d'une bonne partie des gens qui
sont à la commission parce que c'est
assez largement le credo du monde
économique des états qui font l'europe
faut pas croire que les fonctionnaires
de la commission sont totalement libres
1 j'ai fini et bien
on se trompe sur l'instrument qui permet
d'atteindre la paix mais il ya pire
ennemi on va chercher la croissance
débarqué si l'on traité nous devons
faire de la croissance ce qui veut dire
que l'europe à chaque fois que vous lui
dites j'envoie une fusée dans l'espace
un moteur de la fusée tombe en panne est
bien le seul réflexe de l'europe c'est
dire va très bien je vais demander à
amazon de mon livre est un autre
d'accord l'idée qu'on va essayer de
s'arranger avec les moyens du bord c'est
un truc qui est inconcevable
inconcevable pour les gens au sein de la
construction européenne que nous avons
fait
c'est inconcevable au sens premier du
terme parce que c'est pas dans ce qu'on
leur a demandé de faire
on leur a demandé de faire de la
croissance alors quelques exemples on a
mis en place un système de quotas mais
on a demandé sur la croissance donc on
va juste faire croître les quotas un peu
moins vite que le pib
donc ça s'en va commencer à [ __ ] le
système sous contrainte mais enfin sauf
que si le système fait pas de croissance
et que vous retrouvez avec des quotas
plus que le pib n'en demandaient à ce
moment vous vous retrouvez avec un
système totalement sûrs alloués ce qui
s'est passé et des quotas qui se
baladent à 4 euros la tonne je peux vous
assurer qu'à pas un industriel qui a
peur d'un quota 4 euros la tonne tant
qu'ils sont rien un deuxième exemple
aujourd'hui comme vous imaginez que le
problème vous ne pouvez pas imaginer que
le monde se retrouve sans croissance
donc ça veut dire que si c'est quelque
chose qui se passe comme par ailleurs
les limites physiques sont pas dans les
modèles économiques parce que dans les
modèles des gds j'ai eu des arrivées il
n'ya pas l'abonné mais ya pas non plus
les ressources
bon donc comme vous avez aucun modèle ne
vous dit quand le pib arrive à 76 mille
milliards de dollars et s'arrêtent
n'existe pas alors que dans tous les
modèles physiques vous avez des limites
corps quand vous avez parcouru 40 mille
km2 sur internet revenus est votre point
de départ les limites vote à l'école
mais qui a pas de limite donc à aucun
moment on vous dit là ça s'arrête du
coup le postulat de départ c'est ya de
la croissance une fois que la croissance
virgule je vais voir ce que je fais
c'est ça mais du coup vous êtes dans une
quadrature du cercle
l'essentiel du temps donc il ya un vrai
problème au sein de l'europe pour
arriver à accoucher d'une construction
qui est sa cohérence interne parce que
là pour le coup on veut en même temps en
permanence deux choses qui sont
antagonistes
alors dans cette affaire je vais vous
rappeler pour ceux d'entre vous qui
n'ont pas vu ce qu'on avait imaginé au
shift avant l'élection présidentielle
donc à coller un truc qui s'appelait le
manifeste pour des carboni l'europe et
c'était des propositions n'ont pas de
macroéconomie mais de projet c'est à
dire que en gros on a dit voilà un
certain nombre de trucs qu'il faudrait
faire on propose de les faire et puis si
on les fait dans un monde en croissance
tant mieux si on les fait dans un monde
en décroissance tant pis mais où l'effet
corps c'est ça qu'on propose de faire et
l'idée c'est que à cause de ce que le
corps à cause de la courte je les montre
tout à l'heure qui est que si vous
croyez à la dérivée seconde de toute
façon l'approvisionnement énergétique
fossile de l'europe est partie pour se
contracter significativement
de toute façon décarbonés l'économie et
1 est un choix sans regret puisque de
toutes façons de l'énergie fossile vous
allez en avoir de moins en moins de
toute façon l'économie va se décarbonés
au sens premier du terme et on a le
choix entre le gérer et de subir
donc là c'était la proposition sur je
gère alors le premier truc qu'on a
proposé c'est on ferme toutes les
centrales à charbon
je vous signale que contrairement à une
idée couramment répandue l'europe
importe une partie significative de son
charmant l'allemagne importe la moitié
de son charbon elle produit c'est limite
mais le charbon est pour une large
partie importée
donc le ferment toutes les centrales à
charbon et on les remplace par des
moyens décarbonée alors nous aussi ce
sont des pas du tout anti nucléaire le
plus économique c'est de faire ça avec
du nucléaire parce que c'est pilotable
même à 100 euros le mégawattheure c'est
plus économique et les nerfs parce que
c'est pilotable si vous voulez faire
avec des nerfs fait avec des oeillères
on s'en fout ça vous coûtera 5 à 10 fois
plus cher c'est pas le problème
faites le il faut diminuer la taille du
parc automobile et diminuer là
consommation unitaire des voitures la
seule chose que vous n'allez pas faire
ces échanges et d'urbanisme demain matin
il faudrait aussi le changer à long
terme parce que une ville de 10 millions
d'habitants c'est pas vivable
dans un monde à l'énergie contrainte ça
dépend d'un hinterland beaucoup trop
vaste en termes d'approvisionnement pour
que vous arriviez à faire survivre 10
millions d'habitants viable
économiquement
dans un monde à l'énergie contrainte est
en fait le premier endroit où le système
se délite
ça se comprend assez facilement quand
énergie commence à devenir contrainte
c'est dans les périphéries et c'est
assez facile à expliquer pour des
raisons énergétiques
donc il faut et la meilleure manière de
baisser rapidement la quantité de
pétrole consommés par les voitures c'est
pas de faire des voitures électriques
c'est de faire des voitures à pétrole
beaucoup plus petit ça va beaucoup plus
vite
ça se fait à lille au parc de production
industrielle ça se fait à iso systèmes
de distribution de carburant
juste vous mettez une réglementation
très dur pour baisser très très vite
je vous signale qu'on vient de perdre
une manche à bruxelles avec une
réglementation qui favorise les voitures
lourdes qui va exactement dans le sens
inverse
grâce à mes sur les allemands très écolo
comme chacun sait
il faut également mutualiser les
transports dès qu'on peut alors
mutualisé c'est quoi c'est tout les
transports dits en commun dans lequel on
a aussi collé le covoiturage vous pouvez
également mettre la d'enlever ou à la
marche à pied est évidemment il faut
garder des connexions entre les villes
avec du réseau ferré pour remplacer
l'avion quand il aura plus de pétrole
il faut au premier ordre diviser par
deux les flux de matières produits en
europe sont accommodés donc on fera deux
formes une plastique de forme en ciment
deux fois moins d'acier et c est dans
cette production résiduelles décarbonés
largement la production s'il ya des tas
de moyens de faire ça pour électrifier
que de l'électricité sans carbone etc
faut rénover tout le parc de logements
existants et qu'il faut essayer de pas
trop l'accroître
mais ça renvoie à la question
douloureuse de la démographie je le
redis on peut pas avoir une démographie
perpétuellement croissante dans un monde
en contraction sur les moyens enfin un
moment ça se met à coincer donc
donc vous avez un un sujet sur le parc
de logements qu'il faut rendre
carbonique mans plus performants et un
truc intéressant à noter c'est que le
patronat allemand vient de sortir un
document dans lequel il explique que la
bonne manière de faire ça c'est de
coller des pompes à chaleur partout
alors je suis très content de dire ça
parce que la pompe à chaleur c'est par
essence l'énergie renouvelable qu'il
faudrait développer en france au lieu de
s'occuper de panneaux solaires il faut
rénover également le tertiaire public
la raison pour laquelle on a fait une
mesure distingue c'est que le tertiaire
public c'est les gros de la construction
qui sont dessus alors que le pavillon de
banlieue les gros de la construction
sont pas dessus donc si on veut
embarquer les bouygues vinci eiffage
il faut s'occuper des grandes surfaces à
rénover d'un seul tenant parce que ils
ont une vision jamais rénover les
copropriétés de cinq appartements dans
paris 19e il ya la filière bois qu'il
faut renforcer et enfin il faut diviser
le cheptel bovin par deux ça c'est pas
une mesure énergétique c'est juste une
mesure méthane et donc la mesure qu'on
avait proposé c'était on divise le
cheptel bovin par deux parce que le
cheptel bovin c'est la moitié de
l'empreinte carbone c'est même plus que
ça c'est quasiment les deux tiers de
l'empreinte carbone de l'alimentation
mais comme les éleveurs font un métier
difficile
il faudrait encadrer les prix et donc là
je finis sur la question de que faire en
europe
il faut ré encadrer les prix parce que
il faut garantir aux éleveurs un revenu
décent issus de leur travail même avec
moins de vaches élevées et ça vous y
arrivez pas avec des prix de marché qui
vous laisser le marché et faire ce qu'il
veut vous y arrivez pas et pour finir
là-dessus en fait remettre les
contraintes environnementales dans les
prix
c'est quelque chose que vous ne savez
pas faire dans le cadre d'un marché
ouvert parce que dans le cadre d'un
marché ouvert tout le monde est en
compétition avec tout le monde et donc
celui qui paye pour une externalité et
défavorisées par celui qui ne paye pas
pour l'externalité donc temps que vous
avez un marché ouvert
vous êtes incapable de faire payer les
agents économiques pour les externalités
vous ne pouvez pas la seule manière de
faire ça c'est de remettre défense de
frottement donc ces deux partiellement
fermé c'est
deux partiellement encadré et c'est donc
le c'est une forme de planification
finalement et je vais finir par là à
l'époque contrainte quand le monde était
stable il ya un millénaire et bien à
cette époque là la liberté partout et
tout le temps n'existait pas il y avait
plein de systèmes qui était extrêmement
férocement encadrée parce que c'était la
façon de les rendre durable à l'époque
donc qui aujourd'hui on veut basculer
vers quelque chose d'un peu plus durable
nécessairement ça ira avait quelque
chose d'un peu plus encadré je dis pas
qu'il faut faire n'importe quoi
n'importe comment de manière autoritaire
tout le temps parce que je en train de
dire je suis en train de dire que sans
encadrement les trucs ne marche pas
voilà et je crois que j'ai terminé oui
absolument